hey there Joe polish share I'm here with
my good friend mr. Gary Vaynerchuk
what's up man so brother you know not a
lot you got a book tour going on and
you're in Phoenix Arizona at my
headquarters here for on a marketing so
you're kind of a big deal I mean you're
on the cover ink magazine here yeah and
you've got a new New York Times
bestseller Jab Jab Jab right hook okay
which is awesome everyone needs to get
this book we'll talk a little bit about
this and you travel the world so people
that do not know who you are and what
you do how would you describe yourself
if you were forced to and like in
airplanes you know what do you want it's
funny it's funny he's an airplane not
that you were saying is somebody talking
to you in a seat I actually started
struggling a little while ago with the
passport you know you have to say
occupation and when I when I segwayed
from just doing the wine business and
I'll get into that in a second you know
I was like do you remember what an
entrepreneur was a bad word the emember
ten years ago or 15 years ago if you
said an entrepreneur that actually meant
you were like kind of a loser with an
idea right it's crazy and now I'm
proudly and easily can say entrepreneur
even though it's something I've always
wanted to say yeah you know I'm a I'm a
guy who was born in the former Soviet
Union came here when I was three years
old grew up at a very immigrant
lifestyle my dad became a stock boy and
eventually owned a small liquor store
lived the American dream
I was very entrepreneurial lemonade
stands baseball cards really gifted at
it I was making two three thousand
dollars a weekend when I was 13 selling
baseball cards which you know is insane
and then when I was 14 15 I was dragged
into the liquor store fell in love with
the thought of collecting wine because
it was similar to collecting sports
cards when I was 16 17 because I had a
lot of heart to join my family business
but I hated selling beer and liquor at
cost which is what we did but the wine
thing was interesting jumped in didn't
grow up techie didn't even own a
computer until I was 19
realized this internet thing was gonna
matter launched a wine library calm in
1996 and that became the backbone of me
launching a business that grew from 33
to 60 million dollars in sales in 2006
my career took a weird turn I started a
show on YouTube nine months after it
launched called Wine Library TV where I
reviewed wine in front of a camera like
this I feel very
Cosi in this environment that made me
internet famous I was using Facebook and
Twitter to build that show these were
things that nobody thought about in Oh
607 I started talking at conventions
marketing events that led to me writing
a book called crush it that went quite
viral and started this segue of me
becoming a business man in 2009 I
started a company called vaynermedia
with my brother AJ were a strategy and
creative shop for fortune 500 companies
and last few years we've grown from 20
to 300 employees so it's become a big
deal and so you know get a lot of angel
investing Facebook Twitter Tumblr Boober
so is your game now more of this an
investor or a consulting company right
now right now I'm like hardcore core
dirty fingers you know dirt under my
fingers I'm a CEO of an agency it's very
non glam I'm playing a long game it'll
get more glam as I start showing more
layers to it through the years but right
now I'm the CEO of the fastest growing
social digital agency in America which
I'm proud of but its client services
like for all the smart people there's
nothing to you know brilliant about it
right it's grinding client service
business that said it's going to be a
foundation for things I want to do in
the future and that's why I'm doing it
well you know there's you do a lot of
things and get really deep in the stuff
that I mean it's out there but you take
it from a completely different approach
I mean I mean in your in your book which
I read the entire thing I told you today
except for ten pages and I read as much
as I could before you you you headed out
to areas just the last time page no no
no just coming to some of the case
studies that are around tumblr and
beyond that I read everything I mean is
the single most important I want to show
people how I did like what I did all
right pages y'all right pages down don't
know if you can see that from the camera
and I highlight it and when I read books
I like literally yeah I mean I put you
know I write in the things I want to
model which things suck which things I
don't like and the reason is you know
when I read reviews on you know Amazon
or whatever there's there will be
someone that will say you know this book
sucks or it could have been this could
have been that but when I read a book
like this even if you're on a scale of
one to ten think it's you know writing
ability or whatever
you know ten or it sucks or whatever you
have case studies in here and you
actually show people what to do and how
to do it and anyone that has a business
or a cause or something to sell
it would be virtually impossible for
them to not take several of these
templates that you have that you've laid
out with exact strategies and not turn a
book like this into tens of thousands
some companies millions of dollars
what's interesting is you're such a
high-level thinker that I'm curious how
this book translate to someone like you
because this is freaking nerdy deep like
like almost exhausting
you know you like detail-oriented to the
extreme but I wanted to after writing to
very philosophical books and crush it
and thank you economy to really make a
how-to book I mean this is literally
again on the way here from the airport
to here not far we hit some traffic 20
minutes somebody tweeted did you see
this name sorry Nate my the you know
somebody tweeted an actual results to a
facebook status update and it said this
this your post is 95 percent better than
your normal status updates I've had two
tweets showing actual screenshots of
results from people already tangible of
like driving higher engagement and
awareness and that's listen but I'm
gonna be it's watching right now the
only thing I want
if you sell crap I can't help you but
what I wanted to do with this book is
make sure that there are emerging
platforms Facebook Twitter Tumblr
Pinterest Instagram vine in a world
where email marketing open rates are
down from 37 to 12 percent over the last
seven years as a whole an email
marketing I mean I've built my business
on email marketing you've done plenty of
email marketing exactly diminishing
returns add words and Google Ads
are down 15% and click-through right
banner ad click-through is collapsing
and so all these traditional digital
media ways to communicate are
diminishing and there's some emerging
ones and I wanted to write the textbook
for that yeah yeah and it's so from that
standpoint what I a guy like me what
I'll do with this is I'll give it to
every one of my employees that has
anything to do with which is pretty much
everyone communicating with the public
just so they can learn better ways of
doing okay the other thing is I'll pick
and choose which platforms
I'm really me myself I'm going to engage
in with versus what my company's gonna
engage in with and secondly it's
something like the purpose of doing this
video this video is gonna go on I love
marketing it's gonna go to genius
Network I'm getting a copy of your book
for everyone in my 25k group I mean it's
it's something that all of them will
find valuable but it's one of those
things to where to here's the way I look
at it if you're gonna spend 30 minutes a
week on Facebook if you're gonna spend
30 which most people gonna spend hours
on Facebook or Twitter or tumblr or
whatever and you won't take a couple of
hours to read a book on how to do it
better it's not like the time it's not
there it's it's how you're using it and
so you know I have a good sense of your
community I am so aware of why social
media in comparison to a lot of the
other things that have been around
longer is less attractive because so Hue
media unlike digital media unlike email
marketing banner retargeting ads SEO and
SEM video unlike the back of magazines
unlike so many other things social media
actually sucks because it's a marathon
not a sprint right it the return on the
investment on this stuff takes longer it
just does and I'm very aware how
unattractive that was coming from my
lips to a world that's looking for
quicker and more efficient results who
is are you know again an audience that
has heart for work-life balance if you
can automate it it's gonna be better the
truth though is where I'm most worried
about and why I have a lot of passion
why I'm excited to be here and hoping
that people that haven't seen me before
or don't deeply know what I talked about
or watching this or listening to this is
that there's a real issue at hand the
attention of our consumer the people
that we court yeah the attention of them
is dwindling in traditional platforms
we're used to and it's quickly being
relegated to their phone as they swipe
it in and a lot of the time in that
swipe is on one of these ten platforms
and if you do not know how to story tell
what you bring to the table on these
platforms
there's going to be a cross-section over
the next half decade where you will not
be relevant if you're unable to
communicate there yeah I totally agree I
totally agree and so I guess I guess the
question is what is the time allocation
that a guy like you actually spends in
this world because you're an extrovert
pretty much yes I mean you're full-blown
extra I fully love everyone and it's in
in but you work like I mean you're a
driven dude you put a lot of time and
effort into it and you're you're also
willing to vacation and stuff you really
you and I that really makes me very
different than everybody so I understand
that well you know I most most on I
don't want a Lincoln bed you don't want
to link oh yeah okay what he's referring
to as I in my office I have incredible
Buy I don't live here I have a bedroom
that's a 1960 Lincoln that the the
headlights turn on more stuff in this
and by the way I envy this in all my
firm this is not a joke or ask you more
cool so I was like look at this spooning
for them you've cool stuff I don't even
know how to buy stuff you know what I
want
rare jets jerseys what I mean by that I
don't mean rare you can't find them I
mean I make custom jerseys of fifth
string wide receivers from the Jets just
so when I go to the jet games I can
fully impose my fandom amongst all the
others they all wear the normal jerseys
and I'm wearing Greg Salas right like
I'm wearing like Troy Davis jerseys guys
that will play three games in their
career just to set the tone that I'm the
biggest Jets fan in the world
yes when do you think you're gonna buy
them I mean you truly truly have this as
a goal so when do you think that's gonna
happen I mean I truly feel like I'm now
within within the 25 year window I feel
like 25 years from now I will own the
New York Jets
I really believe that is that one of
your biggest drivers I mean it's one
thing about making this go public but
like what do you do this all for I mean
you certainly lime I love the game so
much you know what's so funny I'll give
you a scoop here cuz I like you so much
I'm not even sure if I really care if I
buy them or not but boy do I love the
game more than anything more than stuff
more than more than money more I love
the game I love it the legacy of it all
I write stuff like this listen you could
context for this when we first
crossed paths was when this all just
started happening I was so all in in a
world that most people didn't even know
what it was yet yeah I remember you tell
me about Twitter like literally when it
first started saying this is going to be
a big deal I mean like when it was
brand-new right and so that's why you
know I just remember and so like you
know and for me that matters because
look now you just told everybody but
even forget about everybody mean oh cool
like he was must have been right about
that you know that I care about my
legacy I want to be right historically
because that continues to build me
building blocks right if you know if I'm
right for a long period of time that
really matters right and so that's what
I had passion for I love the game I want
to keep building businesses I want to
keep impacting other people this is a
how-to because I want crush it and
that's so much to me I still get emails
many a month you changed my life do you
know what that feels like for a human
being
well that's what I wanted to do with
this this is the deepest I went with it
so to answer a question I mean at the
end of the day for me it's about the
legacy I want to be known as one of the
great hustler entrepreneurs that wasn't
full of crap that actually you know did
it and did it right and was able to
build actual businesses I have a lot of
pride now that I'm competing against
widening Kennedy and Ogilvy and like not
like you like the real actual agency
companies and I'm beating their faces in
because I'm angry and that makes me
happy yeah well you know getting pissed
off actually is a huge driver for
thing's huge
so I read every single negative review
of the Thank You economy and crush it
before I started writing this really yep
it's why one okay well it's it's you
know you've said it before people that
are familiar with you know that you
actually say that you like your your
critics and that you embrace that I love
them and so explain that explain how
well I respect them like I hate
everybody who gets some level of fame
and notoriety and then people hate on
them and they're like oh they're trolls
the haters like because you've got some
victory you'd completely dismiss
criticism right so to me I listen to it
and I try to say okay I'm not doing a
good enough job storytelling for this
human
and then I look around and see if they
like anybody else and most of time they
do there are very few people who've just
decided to go all in on cynicism and
that be their card and there are some
but they're very few and far between I
also recognize that I am an extrovert
that the first time people consume me a
lot of times is on stage where I come
with fire right I curse my face off
which turns off a lot of people I am
angry I'm competitive I'm like you know
and so there's gonna be a tent now 85%
luckily for me love it and you know I've
chopped sand so I can pull it off but
there's 15% that don't enjoy it and then
I spend a lot of time to make sure that
they get more context on me I'm able to
make sure 12 of that percent now likes
me and there's three that's left and I
listen very carefully to the fact that
I'm very aware that the first time
somebody tastes me right first kind of
observation I'm not gonna win everybody
over
I'm not vanilla I'm very something I'm
gonna decide one way or the other and I
want to listen and learn and evolve and
I respect your a friend probably too the
ink article where I talk about I love my
haters oh maybe not no actually no when
I first saw you say that you talked
about the interview you did with our
friend Murray folio I mean I've heard
you saying in several places yeah and
she was right and so like I I respect my
critics and I try to listen to them now
it doesn't mean that I think they're
right or is in the same way that I don't
think the people that blindly think I'm
a genius are right like I continued to
critically think and try to evolve if
I'm not better than I was when we first
met five years ago what have you then
I'm not doing my job then I'm not gonna
be relevant then I want to be very
relevant forever so you do you think
you'll mean in your mind when you're
younger you know I've had my marketing
company for going on almost 20 years
yeah next year it'll be 20 years I've
been doing sort of 20 year party I'll do
something easy of course
yeah it's gonna be batshit crazy so but
it's it's you know I've been doing it
for a long time and I watch you know
some people that start off really strong
and then they fizzle out and and I've
always listened to that cliche and took
it seriously be nice to the people you
meet on the way up they're the same
people you meet on the way down and you
run across people ten years from today
that you ran in and I think you're one
of these people that really get and
understand that because you're totally
engaged with a shitload of people and
you pay a time price you pay the
ultimate price
yeah in order to do this I do and and I
think your reputation is critical in in
spite us you may rub people the wrong
way and you may not everyone may not
like you but if you never sell [ __ ] to
people don't go out there and in promise
things that you're not capable of
pulling together backing up delivering
upon all that I mean don't do business
with scumbags that sort of stuff and I
think you know one thing about you is
that you really care and engage with
people and that's why you're so bonded I
mean people treat you like a rock star
super super happy and feel really good
at night when I close my eyes that
anybody that has any depth of knowledge
of me feels good about me that every
time I get plenty of emails of people
thinking about doing business with me
and saying I really dug and I'm
impressed
like even the friends that always zing
people they liked you or they said they
didn't know you or they said wow I hated
him but then I liked him again my
criticism only comes from my bravado
because I'm equally egotistical and
humble and it depends on what moment I'm
in that's a second right I equally I
truly believe I'm better than everybody
in marketing I truly do and I truly
believe that I'm still just a kid that
you know sucks and came from nothing and
like I have them both right and so it
depends up one if you edited what I just
said you could have stopped at the best
and marketing and that's what some
people here they didn't take my comment
to consideration yeah and so I get it
and I respect it and all I keep doing is
trying to execute I started vaynermedia
to remind people that one of the best
reasons to listen to me is because I
actually build businesses right right
you know I'm now on my second within two
years of running it growing it by eight
figures and not in information not in
pure execution a retail wine shop an
actual agency that goes for fortune 500
clients I think that gives me a lot of
checks in the right column yeah I mean
do you do you want a like a billion
dollar corporation or is it not those
sort of aspirations what I think I'm
gonna
is building product one day having my
own water or my own bubblegum or my own
shoe brand I think my place is marrying
my two things which is marketing and
being a retailer so in a world where I'm
an investment Birchbox
and love those guys I wish I answered my
Warby Parker opportunity email I blew
that one but direct to consumer product
I don't think I'm gonna build a billion
dollar marketing company or b2b company
I do think my play my exit that buys me
the Jets will come in the b2c space and
I think it will come in the form of
product ok well let's let's talk about
small business owners that are just out
there trying to you know make a make
money you know make a living yeah pay
for their families yes send their kids
to school and hopefully schools like
this where they actually read stuff to
teach them how to actually no hoping my
kids will BDNF students like I was so
that I can spend all my time teaching
them real stuff instead of them doing
their homework oh yeah no I fell I fell
doning an operating a small business in
a community college and I I got a
c-minus in principles and marketing so
they only see minus or above I ever
gotten my entire life was a gym that's
hysterical it's it's pretty sad actually
as a matter fact with this whole
throwback Thursday kind of mean going on
on social media I mean think about going
back to my high school and seeing that
they'll give me copies of my report card
because I really think people think I'm
joking because I've had success it's
hard for though that's what I did I was
literally f student no you you should
you sure knew that German one here arts
if you're watching German one German one
I took freshman and sophomore year in my
high school I got I got 10 grades cuz
you got your four marking periods and
your final right I got 10 grades 9 FS
and one D and I have the Spanish one as
a junior because if you don't pass two
years of language in New Jersey in high
school you can't graduate and if you're
watching senior at Kennedy you saved my
ass she called my mom senior year three
weeks ago my mom never went to a
parent-teacher country like she calls my
mom and goes I just want you to know I'm
giving your son you know ASEA so I
actually did get us see once for
charisma I like him but he can't even
say hello in Spanish that's funny
that's freaking funny
so I showed you this earlier this is
before we started recording this is my
very first business card when I started
a carpet upholstery cleaning business in
1990 yes
and there was an you mentioned no area
codes the other it said superior Carpet
Care served in the East Valley
specializing in carpets upholstery car
interior soul extraction cleaning and
then me and a guy named Craig that I
just really kept it local serving the
East Valley oh yeah you weren't even
know but here's the thing
I win everywhere and I remember why I
ran my first radio ad you know and this
is where I began to despise image
advertising which you want with the
radio was all over the valley so I got a
couple of calls but they would be like
you know 45-minute drives and things
like that and I really learned about
target marketing and I really learned
about specifically identifying who you
want to go to and that sort of thing and
so and I learned mark and he never
thinking I would do what I do today and
that I would teach it to others or run
conferences or any of that stuff I did
it because I needed to eat I needed to
survive and this is why I love what I
write about and why I like social media
social media is the only the only
substitute for money but it costs you
time and knowledge oh yeah so if you
don't have any money you got time and
energy because three things you spend
time money and energy you even have a
chapter in here about effort which i
think is it's towards the end which is
really good so okay we'll talk about
that I mean social networks are the only
place because you've got people what
social networks really are or is there
the plumbing of word-of-mouth in our
society right and so you literally have
the ability to take a picture put it on
a social network that you only have 30
fans on and if it's right you can have
80 fans after it and to me that is very
important listen the reason I gravitate
so much to this is my dad gave me no
money in marketing to build
winelibrary.com
I did ghetto stuff I like made printed
flyers and handed them out at the store
like I had a it was all hacking you know
which is the term they use now but
that's what it was it was just like kind
of figuring it out I love the idea that
if you're good enough with Photoshop to
make an infographic and post it on
Pinterest and you get the one right
person to repin it you go into full
virality
and to me that's why I wanted to teach
everybody the best at-bat for the small
business people that are listening
listen you've got your time and you've
got to learn it and the problem is it
takes a lot of time and and and so what
I what I tell small businesspeople who
we don't could suffer for my company but
I do in general just through Twitter and
trying to help beeps is you've got to
sleep less and you've got to actually do
it it's like if I wrote a book on
getting muscles all this book is is the
same thing as an exercise book that
tells you exactly with no hyperbole how
to get muscles right but you actually
have to do the push-ups and sit-ups yeah
and so what they have to do is sleep
less I mean this is the thing that
pisses me off John I don't know if you
see but like people send me these long
emails of like my life's over and they
want to help and I have no time but I
get so I'm sappy and I'm like fine what
and then I asked him a question like
what time you go to sleep
11 and I'm like you're writing me an
email about the death of your life and
you go to sleep at 11 just go to sleep
of 2 in the morning right like I don't
have time to build this other business
and I have to pay my rent or my student
loans right and and then clean Xbox for
an hour right like like play xbox when
you're comfortable and so I think the
work/life balance thing is really
fascinating to me and so from a small
business standpoint the reason I'm
painting that extreme of a picture is I
think most small businesses do a lot of
dumb [ __ ] that doesn't bring them value
if they audit what they do and cut the
bottom 25% and apply it to storytelling
where customers actually now are I think
they have a better succeeded yeah yeah I
mean completely well going back to your
point about the person I mean do you
think some people are just born to just
not make it some people have the juice
and others don't I mean when I use that
term the juice I mean you certainly are
a guy who has the drive you are charged
I mean some people are batteries not
included I mean what do you what do you
say about that I think that that's true
and I think that everybody who's
watching needs to stop complaining
let me explain I don't want to complain
about my workaholic aspects I don't want
to text or tweet I'm top you're never
gonna see a tweet from me saying I'm
tired this is what I chose to do and
this is what I'm executing on and so I
have all these friends that are highly
successful and they're working they're
really working it's not automated right
but and I see them I saw a bunch of mine
SF where a lot of them happened to be
couple days ago first words of the mouth
I'm tired
not spend enough time with my kids like
so spend more time with them
so I equally don't want to complain of
my lack of time with my kids or my or
too much work or all these flights in
the same way where people like
complaining that they don't have big
businesses yet they have tremendous
work-life balance
they're on the bowling team they see
their kids all the time they're at the
bar with their buddies all the time
they've seen every college [ __ ]
football game for the last three years I
mean they got work-life bound so I what
I think is some people are more driven
and I think some people are less driven
and I think people need to really become
self-aware and not complain about the
grass being greener on the other side
that to me if it bothers me I don't
listen I have friends that are I have 50
friends on a top 500 on Forbes and I've
got 50 friends that I went to high
school with in college with that make
less than $70,000 a year and I'm telling
you right now straight up mix them all
together who are the 10 happiest five
and five yeah yeah totally and so yeah
you know I don't judge anybody else I
just don't like complaining well you
know my friend Dan Sullivan says you can
you you can create or you can complain
but you can't he can't do both you know
I just hate it yeah I don't know if it's
the Eastern European thing was like so
unacceptable in my household I don't
know if I was forum boy yeah I mean you
you know I mean I like to rant and so do
you oh I love to rant yeah and bust
chops and like compete I love to compete
but like people saying like you know
like people think things are luck look
like yes I definitely believe there's
serendipity but like how do you not
understand that of course you're gonna
get luckier if you take 800 at-bats
instead of 32 right right like you know
I get luckier by the less amount of time
so let me let me let me take that isn't
it an example of I think a behavioral
change because you know we can talk
about tricks and techniques and methods
and I don't mean tricks like you're
tricking people but just simple
strategies that work which are in your
book I mean you got like a blueprint
that's a wrestle we're having a very
philosophical conversation
and and you're absolutely right what I'm
like really worried about right now is I
think social media is confusing people
do you know why I competed at the boxing
boxing - most people that are watching
listening right now is two dudes going
into the ring and try to punch each
other in the face mm-hmm do you know why
most boxing matches don't end in a
knockout
because boxing is known as a sweet
science because people that actually
learn how to fight then throw mixed
martial arts into it they actually know
the subtle moves in a body to actually
stop you from getting knocked the [ __ ]
out which is what doesn't have do you
know why there's so many knockouts and
fights outside of bars because we don't
know how to defend ourselves or counter
or move Floyd Mayweather is gonna make a
half a billion dollars on moving his
shoulder like a little subtle move same
thing with social media I truly believe
the far majority of people that are
listening and watching right now think
of social medias like I you know yeah
but like is it does it really work
what's the ROI it's new just the kids
doesn't can you really sell [ __ ] on it
and I know it as a science and that's
what I've tried to articulate I know and
think about what time I'm gonna post
something I mean let's get to that basic
of a level that when all these East
Coast people and there's a lot of East
Coast bias and social networking there's
a lot more content produced under East
Coast in the west coast that all these
East Coast people when they're trying to
sell something and post something at
nine o'clock in the morning cuz they're
fresh already go if your audience also
lives in San Francisco which they do
it's 6:00 in the morning you missed them
like you couldn't await it to 11:30 yeah
and so like you know or if you're
targeting females posting something on
Pinterest at 9:20 in the morning for
stay-at-home mom culture works and so
you're trying to get to young dudes and
you try to sell video games post at 2:00
in the morning and 11:00 and so just the
time and when you post is a science in
itself that most people just disregard
because they're treating social networks
like email services they're just
blasting well and I mean I think until
you actually get in and play the game if
you read about it and hear about it
that's one thing so like if you were to
take negative comments on say your book
or anyone's book that's like a how-to
strategy book that actually works yeah
what you rarely see from any of the
critics is like I read your book and I
tried that and it did
work what you hear is people that [ __ ]
about they never even try anything
they have vested emotional or romantic
beliefs and the thing that you're
countering against yeah exactly
I mean I have TV people coming up to me
all the time people that make their
money by selling TV ads saying ah this
doesn't work I'm like of course you
don't think that you're just the radio
guy from the 1950s yeah yeah yes you
question people mind ask me whatever you
want what part was the most valuable aha
from a tack that were it were a specific
like what was one or two things that you
were like oh that's well I'm cool I now
know that it can be philosophical - I'm
just curious for myself well one thing
you said towards them well you said
marketing is hard you know because it is
it got hot and it's gotten harder you
told us this fragmentation of attention
and the reason why image advertising or
say brand building for the sake of
putting a logo on things out there I
mean you speak about brand in a much
different way which we can we can talk
about is the reason most people don't do
good marketing is they're not willing to
unlearn what to do apply the time to do
it and it's a hell of a lot easier to
throw ego based you know picture myself
my logo than it is to really think about
the psychology and the mindset of
someone that you're trying to sell to
and so here when you talk about context
and in all the different platforms have
their native language which you talked
about that that's that's really critical
because it gets into I think marketing
is applied psychology it's what you say
and who you say it to when you say it
how you said it's all of those things
applied it's not you know just a logo
there's there's so much more to it so I
like that part I like the part on effort
I like the boxing analogy I for years
have you know I've said this numerous
times that marketing is like boxy rarely
you're gonna hit him with a Mike Tyson
punch it's it's I never use the exact
word jabs but I said you know what you
do is you wear people down it's selling
as seduction all of the stuff you to do
is is it's like foreplay I mean you even
make the comparison to dating in here
too so it's it's like before you ask
someone to go to bed with you they got
they first got to know like and trust
you they got to feel safe you got to
have a rapport with them you got to feel
comfortable so and and like you take I
love marketing which is one of the
places this this episode is going to go
I mean at the time we're doing this we
got about 300,000 active
subscribers on iTunes for long well that
a couple years my other interviews
started in 1996 I've interviewed he
asked me earlier how many people I've
interviewed I've interviewed over 400
people and say you're like Oprah he said
yes that was that that was the whole
conversation I mean I enjoy that every
way you know every type of person you
could imagine from the top doctor on sex
addiction to Sandra Day O'Connor I
interviewed a couple weeks ago Daymond
John from Shark Tank we did it you know
video interview here a couple weeks ago
I mean that you know all kinds of people
mostly entrepreneurs but you know but
like so going back to the boxing thing I
give away a ton of free content the very
first thing I did in carpet cleaning
yeah I don't know if you know the exact
story I mean you have a little bit about
gun but not not the specifics is when
when I learned that you know and it's
the things that people don't know that
they don't know that will help them make
a buying decision and when it comes to
hiring a carpet cleaner if the only
choice you have is price you're gonna
always go for the lowest price I have to
give people a reason to do business with
me other than price so one of the first
things that I created before the
internet before websites before email
any of this existing shots exactly yes
yes by the way what do you think of my
Hello Kitty wallet before we went on I
was like this is a legit wallet it is it
is I'm gonna take a detour and explain
this wallet then I'll come back to
consumer guides remind me yeah so Dean
Jackson who we've both me and Dean of
interviewed you for I love marketing for
your last book and Frank Kern who's kind
of a goofball
has given given Dean a wallet from the
pulp fiction wallet that's a bad
[ __ ] yeah that wallet and so
Dean carried that wallet around and
basically I asked him at our last I love
marketing conference I said Dean pull
out your wallet he pulled out a Hello
Kitty walk cuz Dean actually gave me
this and he I go why is a grown man you
know carrying a Hello Kitty wallet he
explained the story of how he had the
the bad [ __ ] wallet but he was
censoring himself because we're in front
of 450 people and he felt like you know
Dean's a really nice guy well or me
either and so basically he said the that
wallet said it he's like this wallet
demonstrates that's awesome and I said
that's fantastic sorry
so I so I started educating people on
how to choose the carpet cleaner so III
had a consumer awareness guide to carpet
cleaning read this guide and you'll
discover seven questions ask a carpet
cleaning for me already I taught them
how to do stuff and that turned into 20
for our free recorded messages by the
end of the 1990s every major phone book
in the United States had one or multiple
versions of my ads running and home
remodeling pest control chiropractic
carpet cleaning gyms you name it driving
people to listen to free record a
message so in a lot of ways those were
jab jab jab
did you explain to the book it's given
away free content I love marketing you
know our goal with high left knee would
was to have the best marketing podcast
in the world giving away information for
free better than what most people would
charge for that's right and people keep
asking me what's your monetization
strategy it's like it's just bonding
with a shitload of piece of global jab
yeah and honestly at the highest level
in this book even though it's completely
dictated to the micro content that we
put out any social networks it's how I
live my life
mmm and the only way you can actually
live your life that way is if you have
zero expectation on the back end see
what works for me and I got lucky this
is not I'm smart this is how I'm wired
I have zero ex I'm willing to jab jab
jab give give give and so Jab Jab Jab
right hook stands for give give give
then ask yeah and I'm okay that even if
I feel and I do sometimes feel like I've
given a lot than when I ask and get
nothing in return it's kind of like the
Bronx Tale where the guy and I think
this is the movie the Bronx Tale were
two kid has the kid that I don't know uh
I mean I've probably seen it years ago
but there's a scene in some gangster
movie help me Dad where the the
gangsters like mentoring a little kid
and a little kids mad cuz he lent this
one other kid 20 bucks and a kid won't
pay him back and he goes you got off
cheap and that's how I feel if I give
give give and then I ask and I don't get
returns I'm like okay I understand and
I'll do it again I actually won't say
after one time if I do it twice I'm like
okay listen this person is viewing the
giving and the taking kind of play a
different way than I am and then I can
walk away and put my energy in other
relationships yeah you know I'll tell
you its first soft life gives to the
giver and takes from the taker I mean
absolutely
it's a karmic thing and there are people
that just are they're the type of
individual where everything's a
tit-for-tat sort of relationship it's
like and and I don't know if you can fix
that without some therapy or some some
real it's okay by the way some people
are very black and white and I can get
you know even though I hate it because
it doesn't come natural to me it's
actually quite and very very fair dude
dude dude dude then there's people that
just take that's the worst of it yeah
and but here's where I break it down
people have not applied this to social
networks the amount of people watching
right now that use their Facebook
account like an email service every post
is listen to my podcast by this dude go
to my seminar buy my thing just
it's alright hooks I don't know if you
know anything about boxing
but even if you know nothing about it
you can figure this one out if you know
a right hook is coming you're ducking
mm-hmm yeah yeah it's a good point see
people love to be sold they hate to be
pressured and if they feel like that's
constant yeah yeah it's it's a setup
everything is a setup in order to get
right the sweet science
that's boxing I think that's fascinating
and I I think social media right now is
very grossly underestimated because I
think the whole world's going long-tail
cell cycle and there's still places for
quick hits but there's becoming a
tougher game to get to people it people
are becoming more cynical to advertising
because the youth has been bombarded
with marketing compared to what we grew
up with the 90s was no marketing
compared to what we see in 20 and so
you've got a romance it even more than
you did in the past yeah I totally good
yeah I have an idea just sitting here
thinking about this with people that
would really want to go deep with your
book and and really you know really
utilize it is I have meetup groups that
we just teach people how to do meetup
groups and when I say teach it's not
like I have any major instructions other
than that I love marketing people can
click on a meetup tab there is a
document that they can download yeah but
some people have them on Facebook some
people just organize it but they're so
every day somewhere in the world there's
probably a hundred people gathering
talking about what we talked about on I
love my super cool way I'm in all kinds
of different countries and we don't
charge people it's just like we just
encourage
to do it yeah them a tool to create more
community yeah yeah there's this a PDF
it's like what questions ask how to
start it and I think a really great
thing for a lot of the people that I
love marketing would be to get Gary's
book and like go through the different
case studies on all the different social
networks and and all the different
things you know it's about seven that
you really covered in depth here and
some ideas of future ones which I'll ask
you about before we wrap up is to
actually discuss them in and even maybe
even organize meetup groups based around
this book where people can show each
other what they're doing it how to do it
because I one of the greatest things of
teaching stuff to other people is it
forces you to look at your own stuff you
know it is I mean when you had to do
this book I know you had to audit your
own [ __ ] and a lot of people are
unwilling to deal it's funny it's just
this this morning somewhere else I said
the biggest thing I'm worried about is
I'm educating people so much I'm always
testing my own theories back to almost
the same thesis of why I respect my
haters I'm actually still right now
today doing things that I say don't do
because I want to look at the metrics I
want to know Facebook's changing or
Twitter's changing and I was equate I
might have to stop for a little bit
because people could be like dude you're
putting a link in Facebook and just
sending it just like you say don't so
it's kind of interesting at night.i what
i mean by that and why I'm saying that
is absolutely and not only do am I also
auditing my [ __ ] at all times
prior to this I'm doing it post this
always in real-time it's the number one
thing I care about yeah yeah okay so let
me go back to this so small carpet
cleaning company as an example what do
you recommend they do should they be on
Pinterest should they be on tell me what
should they do that's a great question I
think first and foremost the number one
platform for a small carpet cleaning
company is to be on Facebook because the
target audience that I'm assuming is not
is looking for carpet cleaners you can
definitely reach on Facebook you can get
hyperlocal you can do your status
updates just in Tucson Arizona and
you're gonna get 84 people but that's
okay because it's back targeting and
getting three people converting in your
local area is better than somebody in
Michigan if you're not a global company
right I think the other thing you need
to really think about is how much you're
gonna spend if anything to acquire a
base of fans in your local area or just
putting out content
and then using your email service and
your website and your word-of-mouth to
build your base you have to start with a
base
I recommend spending a thousand five
thousand dollars if you have it to buy
fans that are targeted in your area and
make just awareness ads what I mean by
that is Joe Gary's carpet cleaners no
offer because what you're doing there is
you're getting people that are opting in
that are high quality because they're
not opting in for the deal they're
opting in because they have some
interest to hear from you mm-hmm then
once you've got some sort of base you
start putting out you did this oh you
know where I'm going with you this is
what this 7 thing step thing you did
that's what I would do it's what I do
with Wine Library TV we're like two kids
from the same pot I put on a wine show
every day to educate people no you mean
we both came from the world of education
based marketing we just and we teach
people how to make decisions I think I
would do fun fact Friday and put out a
piece of content that truly educated
about carpet cleaning even if it hurt me
even if I I would literally readjust my
business model before I'd come out with
what the advice I'm giving to make them
the most educated because you want to be
in the business where the most educated
consumer is going to always pick you
that means you're the best yeah that's
what I've always felt that I always say
that to agent when we started
vaynermedia you know we'd get clients
and and we we would not get clients and
he'd be confused he was like bro they're
just not smart enough to hire us I
really meant that so I would start
putting out content to educate the
masses and shareable stuff
throwbackthursday
you know be fun go find a photo on the
Internet of the old 1960s carpet you
seem that like an old 1960s carpet here
you know but you know you know this
better than I do
those old ridiculous-looking 60s carpet
put a picture of throwback Thursday play
with the slang of society you put that
out there you get you know you get your
daughter to share it because she thinks
finally dad and mom and the family
business did something funny and then
she has friends that share it and the
virality just starts coming you know
I'll have my video guy put a little clip
of this and there so that people can see
this here but you see that office back
there that's my office yes is the part
that's carpet on the wall that's like
shag that that's a little looking like
1960 carpet right there so we'll show a
little so it's a culture and
you put out five ten fifteen good pieces
of content start building value and
trust with the community and the
sixteenth one is we're doing special
this week the right hook so how many
jabs before right hook I mean completely
predicated on the health of your
business
Apple when they launched the iPhone and
there was no competitor even close they
could have right hook it every day right
right a carpet cleaner that's the middle
of the run competing with seven other
players I would jab a lot so let's just
so people like I know very deeply what
you mean by Jab Jab Jab right hook but
let's let's us really take it to the
sizing for them something for them
something for them something for you cuz
I'm gonna tell you something right now I
have I did a little homework too and
kind of followed people that have talked
about your podcast you know last week
and just saw them mention it and then
what looked at their Facebook and
Twitter accounts I'm telling you right
now your audience is in the right hook
right hook right hook right hook
business yeah
Oh most marketers are by the way mine
too yeah you nailed it ninety eight
percent so at its lowest form what can
you give out and that's not a discount
and discounts a sale for you that's for
you maybe gave up some margin don't get
confused I'm talking about content
access yeah what about going on a spree
cast for an hour and answering
everybody's questions and just that's it
with no ask you know you know what's so
funny about that too like it's you know
I've had someone that's runny we're
still the largest training organization
in the world to professional carpet
upholstery cleaners we have 7,000
companies all over the world that have
become members and I have a guy that
runs it for me who is a client that's
you know he became client 17 years ago
he's one of my very first clients and
we're doing a teleconference next week
you know because I have not been very
active I'm very active in terms of you
know we send out podcasts weekly we send
out recording we deeper you know cuz I
used to I used to do programs in person
with me and I literally stopped doing
that and so I just said you know lets us
do a you know hello I love you sorta
call lets us get everyone to reconvene
and I had a couple of people in my
company are like well we're not quite
ready to you know sell the I goes it
doesn't matter we're not going to try to
sell anything we're just gonna get
everyone on the phone and just give them
some best practices
to get a couple of my car let me let me
help people that might be crippled by
the notion of like geez what do I say
what's going on in the music world right
now as DJ's are bigger than actual
artists right DJing content is very
important if you just consume a lot of
content and you put links and retweet
you become a curator that's also
valuable so maybe if you're a small
carpet person you've got 89 people on
your Facebook page but you put a link to
interior design or lon
I mean this is a homeowner right see
where I'm going step out of your zone if
you put a link to like seven steps out
of like you know mow your lawn better
that's still your target demo yeah there
are a homeowner and so it's that kind of
how do you bring value can you curate
content can you create it can I did
entertainment and information because I
happen to be funny when I talked about
wine and people were looking for that
difference oh yeah how often will you
just kind of liquored up when you were
doing this zero I've been drunk like
four times in my life I'm too in good
control of my actions and my legacy
never I mean I'm just liquored up
globally Wow naturally liquored up that
is hysterical so you know but what I
what I really try to do at all costs is
put out right now I'm gonna are using
SlideShare know something I haven't been
using just started using it I put out
two slide shares I really tried to put
out something of quality the first one
was the biggest mistake everybody makes
on Twitter which is they start with the
@ symbol and somebody's name when
they're trying to tell everybody but if
you don't know if you start with the @
symbol only the people that follow both
you and that person will actually see
that tweet so if you wanted to tell
everybody that the guarantee was on the
show and you said at Gary B he's gonna
be on the show today well only the
people that followed us if you said hey
everybody at Gary Vee is gonna be on the
show today then everybody that follows
you would see that this is the
single-biggest this is Twitter's fault
not anybody else's so I put this slide
show it's got two hundred thousand views
already in a couple weeks because it's
valuable Wow
because it's being shared on Twitter
because people trying to do Twitter
better now I'm like I got to do this for
Pinterest and I've got you know you know
so I'm curious like what could we do
with this interview
that will give it the highest likelihood
of watching it the some the number one
thing you should do more than anything
is use this interview as the case study
to become a better micro storyteller to
under to awareness against us let me
explain you probably don't have a tumblr
no no here's by the way I don't do it
super well either even though I was an
investment let's stick here because I
want to be detailed
you should start one you should to have
I love marketing tumblr account because
there's plenty of 14 to 21 year old Huck
you know hipsters that love that love
tumblr right that I've never heard of
you me or anybody else custard and
they're in the streets they're cool
but they want to be entrepreneurs you
take one moment from here where you're
holding up the wallet or where I'm being
silly and you make it an animated gif
you know what am anime to give is right
yeah the looping over you put an
animated gif on tumblr with one of the
quotes from you or me from this
interview and then that quote links back
to the iTunes downloaded this you have
nobody on your tumblr account just like
anybody would when they start right but
you take this interview and you link
your tumblr you blast out an email and
say we're now on tumblr and you get ten
eleven fifty you know it's you know how
it works yeah you start at zero you
build you should do that you should make
an infographic that's female centric
things that you believe the female
psychology would have gotten out of this
and make an infographic and start your
Pinterest board of infographics from
your interviews you get one influential
Pinterest person to repin it and you
could have 10 15 a hundred thousand
people getting new awareness about
yourself and Pinterest is a dream it
clicks out to wherever you want so your
infographic that you made from this
seven fun things Gary said you know what
infographics look like yeah and that
links out to the podcast download I mean
this is the future man micro content as
a gateway drug to awareness to your
bigger thing hmm
that's a quotable I guess Seth Godin
gave me a great review on this a big one
he's a beast so what did i do I made a
quote card his picture I didn't tweet or
Facebook like I would have three years
ago saying thanks Seth and a link to the
review know what I did was I made up
what I call a BS you a branded status
update for Facebook where it's a picture
with his face
you know him color looking up his
classic shot with a quote coming out of
his mouth of the review right mhm
and I posted that on Facebook and then I
targeted to people that are fans of Seth
Godin on Facebook
I sold a shitload of books my French
yeah don't you understand yeah so you
can do the same thing for people that
are fans of Gary Vee and all of a sudden
143 thousand people that seem that are
fans of me on Facebook which is the
number you know seventeen thousand of
them would become aware of this for the
first time there's a lot to be done my
man a lot this is listen um hyperbole
and excited and quotable and charismatic
on stage but I've built very large
businesses through execution this book
is execution how many hours all of them
does but seriously you have a small
business owner who's in here they might
be able to do everything you have the
infrastructure to possibly do everything
that I just told you small business
owners have to really focus on one or
two or three cuz they're not gonna have
the bandwidth them $2 well I'll tell you
like you know I I was living on credit
cards for a couple of years trying to
make my carpet cleaning business work
when I first started at me and that was
my first real business I mean I
delivered newspapers you know I did a
lot of drugs in high school so you know
I mean there was a couple bucks yeah
yeah so cuz I was I was a former drug
addict I don't know if you know that
actually remember actually and you know
I delivered newspapers I had all kinds
of weird little businesses you know
painting on curbs I was you know
entrepreneurial at an early age cuz I
just want we go deep into that painting
on curbs I thought we all kind of enjoy
that so what does that mean well you
literally the word addresses on curb
stencils oh yeah yeah yeah I literally
paint people's curbs cut no okay no but
I between the ages of 16 to 18 is when I
was doing a lot of drugs yeah and
luckily I kind of went through the worst
of it yeah like at 18 years old and then
eventually like when I was actually
going to college one of the jobs I had
was working in a mental hospital and I
used to drive the the people that were
there for alcoholism for drug addiction
to AAA meetings any meetings Narcotics
Anonymous and how do you realize and I
will sit in I would sit in those
meetings and I realized wow you know
what's funny and this is a total like
tangent you know not not anything
relevant to this one of the move
minutes that I admire more than anything
is 12-step groups they have done more to
help people with addiction than every
inpatient outpatient doctor book you
know combined and it's never been built
through promotion that's been built it's
it's a trash cannot promote execution
just works so it's you know when you
look and see what causes things to
happen it's it's it's quite fascinating
to understand that so alright what the
hell was I saying
prior to that I totally forgot as well
it does not we can get I was looking at
human clouds well these oh well let's
talk about like Tim Ferriss if you more
if you were to get in a physical fight
with Tim I'd Wayne you thinking you
would take him he'd be my face in that
being said he's terrible at volleyball
play volleyball with him six months ago
he's off who do you think works more you
were Tim although he wrote 4-hour
workweek I mean you know yeah I think I
think it's closer than people think yeah
yeah how many hours a day do you work
all of them yeah how much you sleep six
seven so I get plenty sleep like I work
17 hours a day
I'm a very eight eight nine to 11 12 I
my wife and I had the laughs of our
marriage when I came
I've been extreme for the last two years
on this lots of hours during the week
more time with the kids on the weekends
I came home one night at nine o'clock
and we were freaking out that we had all
this time and then I like literally were
like hugging and like Oh what are we
gonna do like this is amazing and then
really I got really sad I was like it is
9:00 p.m. at night do you know how it's
because listen when I was building my
library I'd get home at 9:00 or 8 the
story gets low last hour and I was like
I thought I worked more than anybody
back then I mean I was really taken it
to the extreme that being said you know
listen there are no [ __ ]
shortcuts can we just put that to bed
once and for all
I mean like now what Tim's incredible at
and I envy tremendously is he takes a
lot of time and effort much like I've
taken a lot of time and effort to figure
out proper storytelling he does find
efficiencies and scales that I'm very
naturally not good at and could use a
lot of work on that
I just am a big believer on tripling
down on your strengths and not worrying
about your weaknesses
haven't but I envy and marvel at his
ability to really respect scale and
triggers and execution we had somebody
intern with us this summer who has that
passion and there's value in that and
there's definitely things that I wish I
could do that way yeah well so one of
the things that I learned when it came
to selling success knowledge or
methodologies strategies and processes
that I know work and that they would
work for other people is not do they
work or do they not not but it does the
person believe they can work so one of
the one on one marketing well nobody
here's what I'm saying though so like a
lot of people I could see it's not say
well [ __ ] I'm not gonna operate like
you're yeah I I'm an introvert I can't I
can't function like that I you know I'm
just not gonna put that time in so they
they throw everything away and I like
treating knowledge books anything how to
like a 12-step group you know take what
you like and leave the rest I mean
they're like the way you did that you
said emulate and trash get rid of but
that's good well yeah I mean cuz like
there was no no I was saying bad in in
terms of a lot of the case studies that
you wrote in here that you cuz you show
ones that you felt were successful and
why yeah and once it sucked you know
like the LA Coste
I just wrote bad next to that because it
was like interrupting its own
conversation that sort of thing although
this is a great set up for you to have
all these companies buy your book though
because every single one of them's gonna
hear this and of course you're smart
enough to know that so this was actually
he challenged me I couldn't put any of
our companies in it for the competitors
cuz I didn't want anybody think that I
was pandering to that which made it
really tough so yeah yeah I mean we
listen new business is the easiest thing
Boehner Scott so I'm not worried about
that
I'm worried about my legacy I want to be
right about the future of storytelling
in the platforms that are gonna matter
for the next decade and that's why I
wrote it yeah so so what what I what I
was saying about like the people out
there that saying well I'm not gonna do
this right that's so discounting game
right and smart to take pieces I listen
you know what's it's funny you said that
I think as I'm maturing I think this is
a new phenomenon for me I've started
getting a little bit better at siphoning
a little mmm-hmm it's listen that's
certainly probably a backbone of your
success you've been able to take pieces
from I when I hear like athletes like I
don't remember who but he retired and he
said you know I just took a little I
took a little I was like damn
I'm just so all in on me it's why I
don't read right we talked about that
like I'm so insular too like my energy
ball and like my community and watching
people's behavior that's my work yeah
but boy do I envy the people that are
able to take a little slice a little
slice there's somebody who is really
crushing it really killing it and said
something really interesting to me which
was he literally became extremely
fascinated both me and Tim and he said
he literally went right down the goddamn
middle that Tim not gonna this I was
awesome at this vice versa and he just
took both yeah I mean you know see the
beauty of what exists today is there's
an enormous amount of models and case
studies and how to stuff one of my
favorite quotes is from the book of
survival Anthony Green back where it's
like to get through an impossible
situation you don't need the muscles
over Hercules the mind of an Einstein
the reflexes of a Grand Prix driver you
simply need to know what to do and if a
business owner or anything you want to
get in better shape you want to have a
better business you want to make that
you just is all there it's all there
it's execution it's just a matter of
yeah it is I say because I do a lot of
angel investing and I people come in
they're like I've got the idea and like
this is the first time they're meeting
me they're recording my money and my
network and the leverage abusing me as
an investor and within to set I mean I
set the tone I'm like ideas are [ __ ] and
that hurts feelings quickly cuz listen
they flew from somewhere
you know and they're like here this is
their moment you know they I'm very
flattered I know it because I used to do
the same thing I would still do same
thing this was they thought about it and
the first two seconds I'm like I don't
care about the idea tell me how you're
gonna execute it I actually think every
idea is equally good and equally bad so
do you do you see you make all your
decisions on the person's very yes I've
done much better betting on the jockey
than betting on the horse that's great
that's good advice
so what do you think other things for
people that are interested in an angel
investing in with the JOBS Act an angel
list I think a lot of other people
listening are gonna start throwing some
money around over the next decade the
other good thing about betting on the
jockey sometimes jockey doesn't win but
if they you know the jockey
and you could watch how they navigated
because maybe the horse was a dud mm-hmm
sometimes they win a next one I mean you
look at people who didn't win on audio
and bailed on EV and the next thing was
Twitter right you know yeah yeah great
great point well I made a post on on
Facebook before you were to come down
here saying I'm doing an interview at
Gary Vaynerchuk later today in Arizona
what do you think the number one best
most awesome question to ask him of
course because I wanted to engage the
people and I'm gonna send all of them a
copy this interview went so I'm gonna
post it and they're gonna love it
so Bonnie she said I would ask him about
his selfing and well it's like bragging
right yeah and natural bravado so have
you always been like this or is this a
shtick that you had to develop no my mom
is that fault my mom it's it used to be
so much worse I'm about to tell you
story that's so true and so insane when
I was 16 years old I used to walk down
the halls of my high school and truly
think I was the single best looking
person on earth
my mom brainwashed me and built so much
self-esteem in my body that it's never
been able to fill I mean as much as I
try to like become older and learn and
some of it seeps out there was so much
there mm-hmm
that now listen I know I know I and I'm
very proud of it especially because I
know my intent is good hmm let me say
something that paints a picture of how I
think I roll I know there's two ways to
build the biggest building in town one
is to build the biggest building in town
two is to tear down all the other
buildings around you I'm very proud that
I'm one I have plenty bravado and I have
all this but I root for everybody else
equally and if they're doing better or
this than the other thing that I you
know what there's a good point of
success with that too because if you're
someone that celebrates the success of
others which is not what I think most
people do I think there's a tremendous
amount of jealousy and envy and it may
not even be expressed with words but
they're constantly thinking about I got
[ __ ] or it's not fair and it's rocky
or look what happened right to me I'm
the other way I don't do it outwardly
that much I of course on an exit or
something great I'll call an email but
I'm I'm like like Tim had his TV show
they or the other day
like sing they're begging for this to be
like a breakout hit mm-hmm I want
everybody to win yeah by the way I'm
competitive the more other people win
the more like oh I better get my game up
you know like like and so to that point
yes I have bravado yes I have ego but I
have a shocking amount of humility as
well because I also think I'm zero at
the same time it's just a bridge I'm
pulling from opposite directions yeah so
another question was if you lost it all
tomorrow what action plan would you put
together to implement and kick ass like
he lost everything away complexion
this is so dark I'm about to go dark up
until my daughter was 2 which was only
two years ago up until two years ago I
secretly wanted to lose it all mm-hmm I
wanted the Phoenix moment I was like
because I'm so confident that if I was
in fear that I know what to do that uh
boy do I like we could arrange that I
mean you know the action the action plan
would be bait listen vaynermedia was
self-funded with with $0 put in we just
went out and got a client mean if I lost
everything I'd still be me now a lot of
people wouldn't blindly think I was
smart because look I lost everything
right mm-hmm so I'd have to understand
what that would mean to my reputation
but I can sell stuff I'll go so rocks
outside and make them hundred thousand a
year you know what here's the thing the
ability to learn how to sell like that
one yeah the ability to learn how to
sell it market sure I want to teach you
it says I'll go sell rocks outside like
100,000 a year yeah we should we should
do that with the with a little marketing
slogan - all right so here let me do one
more what's the number-one most
important question he gets most the time
and why does he think this is not
important ah I get it out well the funny
part to that question is most of them
people are so fixated this book to you I
think you really you and I are actually
in the psychology business and then we
just happen to do other things yeah this
is not really a book deep that touches
our heart and so people are always
asking questions that are about this
tactics it's about a religion not the
church people always like what color
should we paint the church what kind of
lights should we put in the church how
many parking spots should we have in the
church [ __ ] it's about the religion
so 99.9 got it
yeah 99.999999% of the questions that
are being asked of me are not the
important questions the important quote
a q / iq APR I'm the head of HR at
vaynermedia , the CEO got it yeah the
questions that people are asking are
very are very small minded tactical and
don't matter anywhere is close to as
much as taking care of the customer
having a value proposition giving up
front mm-hmm where what should people
pay attention to like okay with all the
new stuff that's going on you are I mean
habits don't you think it's weird that
when you go to the airport every single
person is looking at a screen don't you
think that's weird don't you think
that's weird that while we were doing
this interview our right-hand peeps are
over there in their screen what does
that mean that means that 10 years ago
are right here people sitting right
there would have consumed and gave us
all the attention and picked up
everything that we talked about and that
did not happen here tonight yeah and
then you even say in the book there's no
there's no such thing anymore of
undivided attention that's gone that's
right and so you need micro attention so
habits consumer habits if you're not
going to iTunes top 100 free apps once a
week to just see what's doing well
mm-hmm it's how I figured out that
snapchat mattered and started using it
it gives you trends it gives you psyche
makes you realize people like gaming
people like escapism with entertainment
people like utility the apps that make
their lives better right people like
social networks that means we like
people if you know pay attention to
people's habits look at your nieces and
nephews pay attention at your 60 year
old aunt now is spending her whole day
on Facebook there's things happening
here people yeah so so last thing I'll
ask you is is well maybe why do you love
marketing I mean you've you've really
jumped really deep into this and you
know a lot of people they hear marketing
and they immediately have this you know
oh it's bad it's it's it's manipulation
less though marketing started to go
through a similar thing as entrepreneur
ship well you know the definition of
entrepreneur they all know if you know
the original definition of entrepreneur
came from in 1804 from john baptiste say
who said in entrepreneurs is an
individual that takes resources from a
lower level of productivity to a higher
level so whenever you're taking some to
you from here to there and a lot of
people think oh there's an an axe let's
create a chainsaw that's
entrepreneurship which it is but if you
take someone's brain they're thinking
their capabilities from here to here if
you just think more effectively you
could you can be entrepreneurial so I
you know I'm a storyteller through and
through I started off with a look by the
way a lot of my success is predicated my
dad I took so much about my mom my dad
stripped so much [ __ ] out of my body
at 14 15 16 mm-hmm
because he is the opposite of me he
actually has insane expectations of
others one strike one lie death it's
insane it's real tough my dad's got a
tough life he doesn't have that many
friends cuz of this he has you know and
but what that did was I was like wait a
minute I can't [ __ ] my dad I'm not
gonna have a good relationship with him
and it's slowly but you're and then the
transparency of the internet but I'm a
storyteller I love the story yeah right
I love the story and so that's what Mark
Mark thing to be a storytelling and you
know it but by the way I want to say
something that's very important to me
storytelling I think the best sales
people are people that sell something
they believe I I so stuff I believe in
like every wine every app the way I sold
you on Twitter I believed I fully
believed and I think that I think that I
love marketing because I think it's
storytelling and storytelling to me is
everything it's everything it's just
it's the fabric of our society today
well you know and for a guy that works
his ass off and who literally from the
time I've known you you've not only seen
you not lose any enthusiasm it's only
gotten bigger and bigger is I think you
know the number one sales job that all
of us need to do every day is we need to
sell ourselves on what the hell we're
doing and a lot of people they
disconnect from that the storytelling is
not just what you tell to the public
what you say on social media it's it's
what you say to yourself and what goes
on in your head and if in
if you just simply tell yourself and
everyone else a better story guess what
you you can write a love story you can
write a horror story I mean your life is
your story is something really important
to what you said because I'm very
concerned about where people take it I
want to add one thing this is a word
that is rarely talked about in our space
that I want to start building more
attention for self-awareness hmm if I
could give anybody who's watching slash
listening to this one thing one potion
inject not hustle not smart self
awareness if you have self-awareness
then you've got a starting point to
success because then you're not gonna
[ __ ] yourself you're gonna story
tell yourself you're gonna motivate
yourself but you're not gonna [ __ ]
yourself and the amount of [ __ ] but
bullshitting to oneself going on in the
world right now it's pretty scary yes
it's incredible so what's that quote you
know a life worth a a life worth an
unexamined life is not worth living an
unlived life is not worth examined so
it's that thing so thank you so much man
always great and I would website real
quickly you have a website for the book
there's vaynermedia throughout your
websites for people they want more Gary
you know what I want to just engage with
people and so that would be Gary Vee
Gary B on Twitter please hit me up where
facebook.com slash Gary that's a little
bit of humble brag very few people in
the world have a 4-letter domain that's
pretty good yeah so get his book it's a
Jab Jab Jab right hook how to tell your
story in a noisy social world I think
you'll find it very useful and get it to
everyone that you work with it as
anything to do with communication in
your company in your organization in
your nonprofit or whatever it is you do
and let us know your comments that I
love marketing com what you thought
about this and share it with anyone you
think would be a find it useful and
helpful so awesome